I would say so I mean there's two
revolutions underway that are
overlapping one is biotechnology which
is not nanotechnology this is mastering
the information processes that underlie
biology biology is a set of software
processes our genes are little software
programs and they evolved thousands of
years ago conditions were very different
it was not in the interests of the
evolution of you of the human species
for people to live that long um there
wasn't very many resources to go around
so human life expectancy was twenty
three thousand years ago thirty seven
two hundred years ago we now have the
means of actually changing this outdated
software we have new technologies that
can change our genes not just in a baby
but in a mature individual RNA
interference can turn genes off new
forms of gene therapy can add new genes
we can design these interventions on
computers we can simulate and test them
on biological simulators these are these
are all new abilities but now that
health and medicine is an information
technology it's going to be subject to
this exponential growth what I call the
law of accelerating returns so these
technologies will be a million times
more powerful in 20 years and it will be
a very different era that's what we call
bridge to the biotechnology revolution
bridge one is what you can do already
today bridge three is the nanotechnology
revolution nanobots that can go and
you've tied your bloodstream and keep
you healthy from inside that's maybe 25
years away but if you go out the 2030s
2040 we will be able to access the
information in our brains back it up
we'll be able to really combat disease
at the level when it's one cell and not
wait until it's the level of an organ
and is threatening your life
some are there's a lot of work going on
in biotechnology really understanding
how the information processes a biology
go awry and lead to cancer
the great strides being made with cancer
stem cells I'm actually working with an
MIT team on a cancer stem cell project
we believe we've identified the cancer
stem cell which is sort of the queen bee
of the colony a lot of chemotherapy does
is effective in destroying cancer cells
but it's like destroying the worker bees
in a bee colony you you need to kill the
queen bee otherwise she'll repopulate
the hive and that's that's the cancer
stem cell and I'm working with a team
where we believe we have identified that
and they're working on ways on
destroying that key cell that really
creates a cancer tumor
there's also promising nanotechnology
approaches little devices in the
bloodstream that can detect cancer cells
and destroy them there are many
different approaches and I think that's
the right approach which is to try many
different avenues we're now actually
able to identify cancer as a software
problem as an information problem where
you have cells that are replicating
without end the mechanism that usually
stops every their replication has broken
down through basically think of it as a
software bug and we can now actually go
in and fix that that problem and I think
we are going to make great strides in
overcoming cancer and other major
diseases over the next one or two
decades
well there's already been dramatic
improvements from information technology
scanning technology is grown
tremendously the spatial resolution of
every kind of brain scanner whether it's
to see inside your heart or inside your
brain is doubling every year and you can
now get exquisitely precise pictures of
what's going on with your blood flow you
can scan your whole abdomen and see if
cancer is developing at a very early
stage these are very powerful tools and
they're going to continue to get more
and more powerful
there's already devices that you can put
inside your bloodstream or just swallow
tiny little they're not nanobots but
there are micro BOTS that you can
swallow and they let go and diagnose you
to gastrointestinal system and and
there's also therapeutic devices there's
artificial pancreas and already being
tested that just like the real pancreas
measure on a moment-by-moment basis the
glucose levels in your blood and put out
insulin in a controlled fashion
so diagnosis is becoming far more
powerful computers can also take all
this data and make a decision a judgment
if you get an electrocardiogram today
it'll come back with the computers
diagnosis and that rivals that of
doctors are the same for analyzing
images of blood cells and so computers
are enhancing our diagnostic ability and
that and that's a new phenomena now that
it's become a computerized process it's
going to be subject to this law of
accelerating returns it's doubling in
power over every year